I want to tell you about a place a place  called Nexus bloody broad I had a nexus  my loss  paradise be hidden away but thousands of  years  can't wait for me and not having a place  to settle down I mean it's about Tommy  civilization me returned to the world  Nexus is our legacy and it is imperative  that we discover what happened to the  elder once the most advanced race in  galactic history unlocking their secrets  will now require total distraction it's  war and it ain't gonna be  ready see the thing is nothing here's  what it seems Nexus has a terrible  secret  rated T for teen  dispatch to drop off 17 clear launch  next our planet Nexus